j'ouvre notre second ébail porte sur ce
constat les Français boudent la viande
plus d'un sur deux à réduit sa
consommation au cours des trois
dernières années le bien-être animal
l'impact écologique et surtout
l'inflation explique cette tendance à
certains consommateurs se tournent aussi
vers des alternatives de synthèse
Jonathan du prieze et Adrien pain sont
partis alors en compte
13h c'est le coup de feu chez blend une
chaîne parisienne de Burger qui décline
toute sa carte carnée en version
végétarienne Sophie consomme
occasionnellement de la viande rouge
mais cette fois elle s'est laissée
tenter par un burger ou le steak laisse
place à sa réplique végétale
ça garde ça a la même saveur
serait dit que c'est pas un cacher
Sophie vient de goûter ce steak un
simili Carné goût aspect texture tout
semble quasi identique à de la viande
bovine sauf qu'il est principalement
composé de soja et de betteraves pendant
un mois l'équipe marketing du restaurant
test ses nouveaux produits avant de les
inscrire définitivement à la carte ils
sont fabriqués par une entreprise
française qui ambitionne de séduire les
indécis on cherche pas à convaincre les
véganes ils sont déjà convaincus et ils
ont déjà une offre les aficionados de la
viande de bœuf c'est très difficile de
faire bouger mais les 80% de
flexitariens en France et ailleurs ils
ont envie de manger un peu différemment
ils ont envie de manger de des à la fois
de l'avion mais aussi d'autres produits
et c'est ces gens là qu'on vise pleine
propose depuis des années une
alternative végétarienne assez burgers
de boeuf mais la chaîne voudrait booster
ses ventes grâce aux simili carnés
à partir de tofu fumé échalotes et œuf
par exemple 5% du chiffre d'affaires et
c'est en évolution croissante donc il y
a vraiment un potentiel là dessus et
c'est pour ça qu'on se pose la question
de la réévaluer de la transformer et
qu'on fait un test aujourd'hui s'il
reste une niche le marché des simili
carnés croit très fortement plus 9 %
cette année de quoi aiguiser l'appétit
de start-up comme Umi cette jeune pousse
française créée il y a 3 ans se pose en
pionnière des fils et végétaux qui
ressemblent à si mes prendre à du blanc
de poulet ça reprend en fait en tout
point les qualités organoleptiques d'un
poulet et donc en fait quand on coupe le
produit on voit ici qu'il est assez
blanc et épais et compact mais en fait
dès qu'on les garde un peu on a cette
fibrosité exactement comme un filet
animal c'est de l'eau une protéine
végétale en l'occurrence du soja de
l'huile des arômes naturels du sel et de
l'acide citrique avec ces filets
innovants ou Miami vise les
professionnels de l'agroalimentaire la
start-up a levé 30 millions d'euros
auprès d'investisseurs et développe des
marchés en Espagne au Japon en Suisse et
bientôt en France en s'appuyant sur une
conjoncture favorable ça a marché qui
est en pleine croissance parce que il y
a plein de personnes qui cherchent à
réduire leur consommation de viande
quelque chose qui est vraiment accéléré
par l'inflation l'inflation et
l'augmentation des prix de la viande
parce que le moment de la viande rouge
ça va vraiment eu un impact assez
négatif sur la consommation de viande et
en fait nous on vient offrir une
alternative qui est qui est plus saine
pour l'environnement pour les animaux
pour la pour nous aussi ou Miami est en
passe de recruter 70 collaborateurs pour
lancer une gigantesque cuisine de
production en Alsace à terme la start-up
ambitionne de produire 15000 tonnes de
viande végétale par an
voilà ces alternatives à la viande on y
reviendra un peu plus tard dans notre
débat je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités gainael Go bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes directrice générale de l'opso
Call observatoire société consommation
Benoît Granier bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue
responsable alimentation du Réseau
Action
Climat fait partie des 70 organisations
avant pour l'environnement qui viennent
de
d'envoyer au gouvernement la première
ministre un courrier pour y demander de
résister à la pression des lobbys pour
présenter une stratégie de
l'alimentation à la hauteur des enjeux
écologiques on y reviendra évidemment
Guillaume Gauthier bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes éleveur de charolaise en
Saône-et-Loire secrétaire général de la
fédération nationale bovine et puis vous
êtes également le responsable
environnement de l'association nationale
interprofessionnelle du bétail et des
viandes Émilie zappalski évidemment est
resté à mes côtés je vous propose un
sondage tiens à regarder pour ouvrir
notre débat sondage de qui date du mois
de mars dernier pour Toluna et Harris
interactive à quel question posée aux
Français à quelle fréquence
consommez-vous de la viande tous les
jours 27% des personnes interrogées
quelquefois par semaine mais pas tous
les jours 50% une fois par semaine 12
quelques fois par mois 6% moins souvent
3% jamais 2% gainaëlle Go si on fait un
constat de la consommation que disent
les derniers chiffres en manière en
matière de consommation notre titre
c'est pourquoi les Français bougent-ils
la viande est-ce que effectivement cette
tendance elle se confirme
alors la consommation de viande baisse
un peu et se transforme en fait ce qui
est ce qu'il faut voir c'est que depuis
60 ans elle a doublé en fait et on a
connu un pic durant les années 90 et
depuis les années 90 alors c'est un peu
c'est un peu baissé et puis maintenant
ça se stabilise alors d'une année sur
l'autre il peut y avoir des petites
variations
il y a plusieurs facteurs en fait qui
qui expliquent ça il y a évidemment et
vous c'était mentionné dans votre
reportage la question de budgétaire
l'inflation
et puis il y a trois autres facteurs qui
sont importants la question et on y
reviendra sans doute aussi la question
de la santé la question de
l'environnement et en fait de la
condition animale et donc ces quatre
leviers là concourent à ce que il y ait
une interrogation en tout cas est-ce que
on change un peu ces comportements
vis-à-vis de la viande et ça se
transforme aussi
que la baisse c'est pas fait elle est
pas si franche que ça quoi c'est ça non
il y a une baisse il y a une un
changement dans la façon dont on
consomme la viande il y a une une
surdécration du fait qu'on baisse sa
consommation ça c'est intéressant parce
que parce qu'effectivement vous avez
vous avez publié Benoît Granier avec
Harris interactif décidément un
baromètre de la consommation de viande
des Français le précédent il datait il y
a deux ans exactement et donc qu'est-ce
que vous en tout cas dans le déclaratif
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui ressort de
ce baromètre dans le déclaratif on se
rend compte que la proportion des
Français qui déclare avoir élu sa
consommation de viande au collet 3
dernières années a augmenté de 9 points
on a atteint 57%, et on a la même
augmentation de 9 points si on regarde
la proportion des Français qui
souhaitent réduire la consommation de
viande à l'avenir donc le fait que ces
deux items soient en augmentation on
montre bien la prise de conscience par
contre c'est vrai que si on regarde les
bilans comptables de consommation de
viande on n'a pas forcément cette baisse
qui va s'observer et là on peut
expliquer par différents facteurs sur
lesquels je pourrais revenir c'est que
même si on a la conscience et l'envie de
consommer moins de viande en se heurte
toujours à des difficultés du fait que
quand on va au restaurant on a très peu
de choix sans viande quand on va dans la
grande distribution le Réseau Action
Climat a aussi sorti un rapport sur le
sujet il y a quelques mois que je vous
ai amené
92% des plats préparés contiennent de la
viande ou du poisson et si on regarde
aussi les publicités le marketing en
magasin et les promotions c'est
systématiquement pour de la viande le
plus souvent d'origine industrielle donc
on a en fait tous les facteurs qui vont
inciter finalement à une surconsommation
de viande qui plus est souvent de
mauvaise qualité et souvent importés ce
qui est problématique alors ça
évidemment c'est un enjeu majeur sur
lequel on reviendra comment préserver
l'élevage français et la qualité de la
viande française dans ce contexte
général mais sur votre constat personnel
sur effectivement baisse de consommation
de viande ou pas est-ce que vous vous le
ressentez dans votre production dans la
façon d'écouler
vos produits ou est-ce que vous dites
non c'est une mutation on consomme
différemment
je pense qu'on consomme différemment on
s'aperçoit par une méthode qui est la
méthode des bilans en fait c'est on
prend la production française les
imports les exports et en fait on tient
un bilan et sur les 2022 c'est plus 1 %
de consommation de viande rouge d'accord
alors effectivement vous avez parlé du
prix c'est oui c'est c'est quelque chose
qu'on reviendra dessus mais après ce qui
nous dérange plus en tant qu''éleveur
c'est
on y reviendra certainement 6 c'est on
perd des éleveurs on perd du cheptel
allaitant les pieds également mais on
consomme toujours autant de viande et en
fait on favorise une chose c'est
l'importation de viande alors moi qui
suis éleveur français je sais le modèle
que je défends je sais l'élevage
herbaget que je produis en
Saône-et-Loire je peux que être un peu
un peu un peu énervé je dirais par les
importations qu'on peut avoir et le
consommateur enfin vous l'avez dit mais
le consommateur
il va en restauration que ce soit la
restauration rapide de la restauration
traditionnelle alors il a un souhait
c'est de manger un peu moins de viande
mais finalement dans son assiette
il le fait pas forcément oui alors ça
c'est intéressant sur la différence
peut-être entre le déclaratif et la
consommation réelle ça veut dire que
souvent on va consommer de la viande au
restaurant et pas avoir l'impression
qu'on en consomme parce qu'on en a pas
acheté chez un boucher ou supermarché
est-ce que c'est ça la vie
complètement c'est à dire les
comportements
au promis parfois l'équilibre des
équilibre respirations qui poussent
justement vers une moindre consommation
de viande en tout cas une consommation
ils ont moins aimé mieux de de viande et
puis il y a il y a les contraintes qui
alors les contraintes peuvent aussi
aller dans le même sens puisque on voit
qu'elle est contrainte budgétaires après
cet écart il est il est intéressant
parce qu'il manifeste justement les gens
déclarent consommer moins de viande
parce que ils voudraient consommer moins
de viande parfois ils ne peuvent pas il
y a aussi effectivement de la viande un
peu invisible c'est à dire cette viande
dans les produits transformés en fait
quand on leur demande s'il consomme de
la viande les gens n'ont pas toujours le
sentiment de l'associe pas toujours à
cette viande transformée est-ce qu'on
peut trouver dans les plats préparés et
de la même façon ce qui a beaucoup
augmenté en termes de consommation c'est
tout ce qui est restauration hors
domicile ou hors domicile fabriqué en
domicile et livré à domicile et par
exemple quand vous demandez aux jeunes
qui consomment de la viande ils vous
disent non en revanche il faut leur
demander s'il consomme des burgers ou du
kebab ils vous disent oui et donc là en
fait c'est la viande c'est de la viande
c'est sûr que c'est pas l'image de de la
entre autres mais c'est de la viande
quand même donc c'est pour ça que il y a
à la fois oui c'est vrai un
questionnement et et sur sa consommation
de viande et le désir c'est pas pour
rien que en 2018 je crois le mot
flexitarien est rentré au dictionnaire
parce que justement c'est c'est un moyen
de se dire bon ben je et on voit dans
nos études que c'est une réalité aussi
moins de viande effectivement pas tous
les jours comme vous vous le voyez là
mais il y a aussi voilà une viande une
viande plus discrète une viande qu'on
voit moins qu'on identifie moins qui
monte dans les représentations de ce qui
était la viande moi je trouve ça bien de
se dire on va manger peut-être un peu
moins de viande mais pour se faire
plaisir de la viande de qualité de la
viande française c'est un peu ma
démarche Emilie j'ai l'impression qu'on
reste très schizophrène sur le citoyen
qui veut faire bien pour l'environnement
pour la santé tout ça et puis le
consommateur qui regarde son
portefeuille et qui va toujours acheter
un petit peu de la qualité dégradée ou
toujours quand il a pas mais on sent
quand même qu'il y a une espèce de
tendance et on le voit dans les
nouvelles génération qui font beaucoup
plus attention à je mange deux fois de
la viande dans la journée c'est pas
possible qu'ils en mangent à la cantine
le soir mais des difficultés aussi je
pense dans les habitudes je parle en
tant que mère de famille ou en tant que
voilà pour consommer parce que c'est
vrai que ça fait des années qu'on
consomme de cette façon là et comment
remplacer comment faire des recettes qui
soient équilibrées qui apportent autant
de protéines on peut pas manger des œufs
toute la journée tous les jours et ça je
pense qu'il y a une espèce d'éducation
ou d'apprentissage pour savoir comment
on fait autrement avec de la qualité et
puis autrement sans viande pour garder
des nutritions correctes alors je
voudrais qu'on se concentre ensemble
maintenant sur la question du prix
si la consommation malgré tout baisse
enfin le premier élément qui est donné
en explication c'est quand même le prix
depuis quelques mois voire plus d'une
année je voudrais je vous propose
d'abord un témoignage tient un
témoignage d'une cliente de supermarché
elle témoigne de ce qu'elle vient de
voir ça se passe dans un supermarché en
banlieue de Marseille
quand j'ai vu un monsieur âgé regardez
ce qu'il avait dans son porte-monnaie et
il a acheté la moitié d'une baguette de
pain et une petite belle plaquette de
beurre et puis regardez la viande et
regarder la viande et on sentait qu'il
avait fait et puis il a pris la viande
et il a mis sous le chapeau
ça met un peu choqué mais après je me
suis dit bon ça me regarde pas
des vols de nourriture à l'étalage ma
figurez-vous voilà l'étalage plus 14,7%
en 2022 et encore la plupart de des
voilà de ces vols de nourriture dans les
grandes surfaces elles sont pas
déclarées à la police ça se règle à
l'amiable souvent
dans le magasin bon voilà c'était une
illustration je voudrais maintenant
qu'on prenne un peu de recul par rapport
à un témoignage qui est voilà qui est
choquant qui est assez émouvant d'une
certaine façon même si on va pas dire
aller voler dans les magasins évidemment
mais si on revient un peu à la brutalité
des des chiffres le prix ça représente
quoi dans le par rapport à l'inflation
l'augmentation du prix de la viande
depuis depuis quelques mois là en fait
l'in
flation elle est de 6% sur un an
mais surtout en fait ce qui est
compliqué c'est qu'aujourd'hui elle pèse
principalement sur les dépenses sur les
sur les produits alimentaires
c'est-à-dire c'est 6% d'inflation
globale mais c'est 15% d'inflation sur
l'alimentation et donc et ça peut même
être alors pour les produits justement
les produits un peu phares de dire les
pâtes le riz les œufs c'est parfois
jusqu'à 20% et sur certaines viandes ou
poissons ça peut aller jusqu'à 30 et on
en parlait c'est-à-dire la viande la
viande de bœuf l'inflation n'est pas est
plutôt dans la moyenne mais les prix
sont déjà enfin sont plus élevés
globalement donc en fait voilà ça pèse
énormément et il y a un chiffre
peut-être à l'oxyco j'ai regardé juste
avant de partir qu'on mesurait qu'on a
mesuré là c'est à dire il y a si vous
avez à choisir entre le prix et la
qualité qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous
faites et aujourd'hui on a 58% qui nous
disent minimiser le budget
parce qu'il fallait faire des sacrifices
sur la qualité plutôt que privilégier en
fait la qualité 62% c'était à peu près
une proportion inverse il y a deux ans
donc on voit là on voit les gens qui se
restreignent qui se restreignent sur
leurs dépenses alimentaires et on a même
un Français sur 10 qui dit vraiment sur
restreindre de manière très importante
aujourd'hui on pourrait se dire que
cette période d'inflation bah c'est une
opportunité pour effectivement modifier
un peu nos comportements manger on fera
après le bilan on va dire
environnemental de de la viande
évidemment ensemble mais voilà modifier
nos comportements sauf que si ça se fait
en fait au détriment d'une viande de
qualité un peu plus chère pour acheter
des produits transformés moins chers
avec de la viande de mauvaise qualité on
marcher sur la tête quoi complètement
d'accord c'est vrai qu'on a une
difficulté en France aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on va vers une alimentation à deux
vitesses millions de tension avec des
produits frais des fruits et légumes
locaux du bio de la viande de qualité
pour les ménages aisés et à l'inverse on
a les populations les plus modestes qui
doivent manger les produits transformés
peu de produits frais et de la viande de
mauvaise qualité qui met en danger leur
santé et face à cette difficulté
la solution c'est vraiment les
politiques publiques de se dire est-ce
que on peut aller vers un système
d'alimentation à deux vitesses ou est-ce
qu'on souhaite que ce droit a une
alimentation de qualité soit assuré à
tous les consommateurs et là il y a
différents leviers un levier c'est de
renforcer les capacités financières des
ménages il faut savoir que l'aide
alimentaire en France a doublé au cours
des années 2010 on a 8 millions de
personnes en insécurité alimentaire en
France aujourd'hui c'est indigne d'un
pays comme la France et dans cette
situation consommer des produits de
meilleure qualité c'est quasiment
mission impossible donc il y a vraiment
un enjeu très important d'agir au niveau
de la demande donner plus de moyens et
aussi après un levier vers les éleveurs
exactement de soutenir les modes de
production surtout les modes qui sont
plus vertueux au niveau écologique
aujourd'hui on a encore un rapport de la
Cour des comptes de l'an dernier qui
montre bien que ce problème du prix
élevé du bio il est non seulement parce
que la grande distribution fait plus de
marge soit les produits frais soit les
produits bio et sous labels dont sur du
Label Rouge de viande bovine par exemple
mais il est aussi parce qu'il y a pas
assez de soutien financiers pour les
élevages et les agriculteurs en agroé on
élevage biologique ce qui suscite aussi
un prix qui est plus élevé sans parler
après des problèmes de rapport
déséquilibrés entre la grande
distribution et les éleveurs qui fait
que les coûts de production sont pas
pris en compte la rémunération n'est pas
assurée alors je vais vous donner la
parole là-dessus tout de suite
évidemment je vous propose d'abord
d'écouter un de vos collègues qui
s'appelle Serge estevin et éleveurs
bovins il était en début du salon de
l'agriculture en train de de s'installer
et il dit attention et ça reprend un peu
votre discours à ne pas favoriser la
viande importée on l'écoute on va
essayer de faire passer le message
aux politiques aux hommes politiques
monsieur Macron également au député qui
seront là j'espère et également aux
consommateur que aujourd'hui il vaut
mieux peut-être moins manger de viande
en l'occurrence pour se qu'on représente
et
manger un produit de meilleure qualité
dont on connaît l'origine voilà
Guillaume Gauthier une grande de qualité
produite en France ça coûte forcément
plus cher aux consommateurs il y a pas
enfin voilà c'est c'est basique
oui oui ça peut oui forcément on exige
une une une alimentation différente des
des élevages plus extensifs etc donc
moins de bête par hectare et cetera de
la prairie bien évidemment c'est de
ruminants donc ça paraît logique
effectivement ça coûte plus cher mais
alors il y a le phénomène d'inflation
aujourd'hui mais la viande en
GMS
pardon elle a augmenté depuis des
dizaines d'années c'est-à-dire elle a
toujours eu une montée progressive
c'est-à-dire que le prix de la viande
toujours augmenté ce qui est paradoxal
parce que en même temps vous lui dites
la consommation
augmente depuis des décennies donc ça
c'est démocratisé aussi parce que le
pouvoir d'achat augmente en comparaison
ouais enfin l'avion augmente le
producteur et la très très peu augmenté
durant les 30 dernières années elle a
augmenté l'année dernière un petit peu
effectivement même si nos charges ont
rattrapé notre prix de vente mais
on lance le débat sur la santé
vous serez pas tous d'accord autour de
cette table non ça va devenir technique
mais non mais bon on peut on peut le
lancer après tout allons-y on a gagné
qu'est-ce que vous la question
consommation de viande ou alors
peut-être je vais dire surconsommation
de viande et fait sur la santé oui c'est
vrai qu'il y a des difficultés par
rapport à la consommation de viande
c'est la surconsommation d'un point de
vue purement environnemental mais
l'université climat il n'y a pas de
nécessité d'arrêter de manger de la
viande c'est un peu comme un thermostat
pour le chauffage vous êtes à 25 degrés
l'hiver c'est un peu excessif on vous
demande pas de couper le chauffage on
vous demande de passer à 20 ou 21 la
consommation de viande c'est un peu
pareil on mange deux fois plus de viande
aujourd'hui que la génération de nos
grands-parents en France la consommation
de viande c'est aussi deux fois plus que
la moyenne mondiale et quand vous
regardez tous les scénarios
scientifiques d'agence public etc pour
avoir une alimentation durable il
faudrait baisser la consommation de
viande de 50% à horizon 2050 donc en
fait revenir à un niveau raisonnable le
rôti du dimanche qu'on avait autrefois
c'est devenu un rôti de tous les jours
et bah faut peut-être questionner ça et
d'ailleurs si on veut consommer de la
viande de qualité qui est plus cher on
peut pas en manger autant ça coûte
beaucoup plus cher et en termes
d'élevage on n'a pas non plus les
capacités de manger autant de viande en
produisant avec des élevages durables
toute cette viande en France et d'un
point de vue santé c'est vrai que la
consommation de viande elle est
impliquée si on en consomme en excès
dans la hausse de pas mal de maladies
comme l'obésité le diabète de type 2
certains cancers et à l'inverse il y a
des études récentes qui montent il y en
a une alimentation plus végétale donc
plus de fruits et légumes de protéines
végétales comme par exemple des céréales
complètes des légumes secs on peut
gagner jusqu'à 10 années d'espérance de
vie donc il y a vraiment un enjeu
important à aller vers le moins ému et
plus de végétal mais alors c'est quoi la
surconsommation à partir de à partir de
de quel fréquence de consommation de
viande rouge on considère que c'est de
la surconsommation alors attention c'est
pas que la viande rouge voilà parce que
la viande rouge c'est le poète la
charcuterie le beurre par exemple la
charcuterie qui pose des problèmes
encore plus important vis-à-vis des
nitrites qui sont vraiment appliquées
dans les cancers colorectaux mais la
volaille aussi des impacts envir un taux
très élevé notamment du fait que c'est
en France des poulets sont dans des
élevages intensifs et vous avez des
impacts en termes de déforestation de
pollution locale de pollution de l'air
qui sont très importants et c'est en
plus des élevages très dépendants des
importations pour l'alimentation animale
donc là c'est un autre sujet mais on est
grosso modo à 100 g de viande par jour
et par personne en France aujourd'hui et
donc dans les différents modèles qui
existent pour aller voir une
alimentation qui serait durable et saine
à la fois on estime que la baisse oui
elle est entre 30 et 70% en moyenne 50%.
donc on passe à 50 g par jour donc c'est
en manger une petite portion par jour
par exemple en fonction du type de
viande qu'on va avoir est-ce qu'on peut
garder le même nombre de d'éleveurs et
je disais en titre c'est prairies qui
façonnent le paysage français depuis des
siècles c'est voilà c'est aussi ce qui
fait la beauté de notre notre pays
est-ce qu'on peut garder le même nombre
d'éleveurs avec une telle baisse de la
consommation non ça c'est clair alors
c'est déjà le cas on perd des des
éleveurs par contre sur la viande je
pense qu'il est important
dans la consommation de viande de de
mettre à part aussi la viande rouge je
pense qu'on en consomme un petit peu
moins que ce qui est recommandé
nationalement c'est 500 grammes par
semaine on est en consommer 300 20 g si
je vais être précis j'ai vu quelques
chiffres je suis pas expert non plus
mais effectivement après il y a des
excès il y a 20 % des personnes qui en
mangent trop et 80% qui sont en dessous
de la moyenne donc c'est pareil le
public de jeunes enfants doit en manger
aussi pour on va pas trop rentrer
là-dedans mais par rapport à votre
question non c'est clair si si on baisse
notre consommation de viande et encore
il faut voir quelle viande la viande
rouge
clairement on perd aujourd'hui des
éleveurs des vaches donc des éleveurs et
on perd aussi de la prairie alors on va
parler maintenant de on va faire un peu
de politique parce que quand on parle
d'alimentation Émilie on parle politique
aussi il y a des liens on peut faire le
lien entre l'alimentation et orientation
politique dis-moi est-ce que tu manges
et je te dirai pour qui tu votes on
n'est pas loin parce que l'alimentation
est vraiment on passe de devenir un
geste très politique alors on a eu un
Sandrine Rousseau vous vous souvenez
député écologiste et Fabien Roussel le
patron du Parti communiste ancien
candidat à la présidentielle qui se sont
disputés sur les valeurs de la viande et
du barbecue la première estimant que le
barbecue était un symbole de virilité
qu'il fallait en finir le second assurer
qu'on mangeait la viande en fonction de
ce que l'on avait dans son porte-monnaie
et pas en fonction de ce que l'on avait
dans sa culotte ou dans son slip les
deux c'était déjà disputés non pas au
sujet du sexe des escalopes mais sur le
top 3 de la gastronomie française
Roussel parler d'un bon vin d'une bonne
viande d'un bon fromage et Sandrine
Rousseau lui remarqué que le plat
préféré des français c'était le couscous
je crois que le deuxième c'était le
kebab en France donc la nourriture a
toujours eu une importance primordiale
c'est pas vous qui allez qui allez me
contredire là-dessus avec un poids
culturel très fort et tous les nouveaux
enjeux dont on a parlé le bien-être
animal la santé l'empreinte aussi
carbone sont venus renforcer cette
politique de l'alimentation comment elle
se traduit cette politique chacun essaie
de se positionner vis-à-vis de cette
nouvelle donne alimentaire au politique
certains sont très radicaux à l'image
d'Aymeric Caron député LFI qui assure
qu'on ne peut pas être écolo et manger
de la viande comme il a affirmait hier
dans un tweet d'autres sont plus
nuancées alors on a Emmanuel Macron avec
son célèbre en même temps qui s'applique
aussi au culinaire puisqu'en 2019
c'était au salon de l'agriculture le
président s'était dit consommateur de
viande et de viande rouge je crois
d'ailleurs mais il trouvait aussi le
message des flexitariens intelligents à
tous égards donc une façon de satisfaire
à la fois les agriculteurs et de l'autre
les partisans d'une diminution de la
consommation en viande en même temps
effectivement je suis assez comme ça moi
je penche de la viande de temps en temps
et flexible
ça fonctionne pas mal alors au niveau du
gouvernement quelle position alors il y
a une expérimentation qui a été menée au
sein des ministères en novembre 2022 et
ça montre à quel point les choses sont
pas encore très claires dans ce domaine
il y avait un menu végétarien qui était
imposé au ministère un menu végétarien
une fois par semaine alors les réactions
étaient assez variées certains ont tout
de suite pris le pli on parle des
conseillers de Marlène Schiappa qui sont
pour la plupart végétariens qui sont
même à plusieurs repas vegan par semaine
mais alors d'autres ont été très
critiques et on critiqué notamment les
ayatollahs verts qui leur imposaient ce
repas par semaine et même au ministère
de la transition écologique ses repas
n'ont pas fait recettes des polémiques
persistent aussi sur les menus
végétariens qui sont maintenant proposés
et même bientôt imposés dans les
cantines scolaires du fait de la loi
egalim de 2018
il y a un dispositif qui risque de de
revoir à la baisse tout ça parce qu'il y
a un arrêté ministériel qui est en
fabrication qui imposerait une quantité
minimale de viande et de poissons dans
les cantines alors tout de suite il y a
une réaction d'élus de tout bord qui ont
fait une tribune dans Le Monde en
février 2023 pour s'opposer contre cet
arrêté pour éviter de détricoter tout ce
qu'on venait de tricoter envers encore
aujourd'hui au Sénat parce que ce mardi
proposition de loi pour un choc de
compétitivité en faveur de la ferme
France je cite qui a été présenté et on
voit très clairement une opposition
entre la majorité et l'air du Sénat qui
porte ce texte et les parties de gauche
notamment écologiste qui parle je les
cite là encore de régression
environnementale je reviens un peu au
portrait robot ça me fait penser c'est
en vous entendant rappeler la polémique
autour du barbecue le portrait-robot de
du mangeur de viande en France
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est plus
souvent un homme c'est oui alors c'est
c'est vrai que
que les hommes consomment un peu plus de
de viande quotidiennement je crois que
c'est en moyenne 100g vous disiez par
jour pour les femmes et je crois 138 g
j'ai regardé pour pour les pour les
hommes je pense que après il y a des
différences aussi qui peuvent venir de
en effet de catégorie
socio-professionnelles c'est à dire que
justement on va peut-être être plus sur
une viande piée dans salir des pièces de
viande pour les catégories
socio-professionnelles privilégiées qui
vont acheter moins mais mieux et donc
d'une viande de super qualité comme vous
le disiez et de la viande plutôt qui va
être transformée pour pour les
catégories plus populaires une viande
aussi qui a qui s'est transformée pour
les jeunes qui n'en consomment alors ça
dépend mais il y a plus une proportion
plus importante de végétariens chez les
jeunes mais il y a aussi toute une
proportion de jeunes qui en consomme
plutôt plus donc ce qui ce que ça
signifie pour moi surtout parce que le
débat justement la translation sur le
domaine politique et finalement
identitaire il se fait sur des polarités
en fait et on discutait là d'une
transition c'est à dire on est tous et
même des
la grande distribution reprend le terme
de la transition alimentaire on peut pas
passer directement d'un modèle à un
autre et finalement en France il y a les
deux 2% de végétariens de virgule 2% de
végétariens et donc c'est pour ça qu'on
a vu en fait apparaître ce terme de
flexitarien c'est qu'on a déjà sur la
question alimentaire 30 à 40 % de
Français qui sont engagés dans une un
changement de leur comportement ou en
tout cas la volonté de changer leur
comportement il y a effectivement des
gens qui vont être très militants à
l'intérieur mais dont la proportion les
entends plus il y a des gens qui ne
veulent rien changer mais d'un côté les
traits militants les enfants on va se
focaliser en fait sur ces deux polarités
alors que tous les Français en fait ils
sont au milieu de ça c'est-à-dire il y a
ceux qui sont des gens en mouvement il y
a ceux qui s'interrogent et qui
aimeraient mais qui n'ont pas forcément
accès puis à ceux qui suivent vous voyez
mais en tout cas justement en faire une
question à défaut en plus d'être
citoyenne qui peut devenir identitaire
c'est quand même assez c'est dommage
parce que c'est un sujet majeur et c'est
et c'est réducteur en fait alors je
voudrais que sans être réducteur et est
trop caricaturaux évidemment c'est le
notre objectif quotidien cette émission
qu'on se concentre maintenant sur la
question de du bilan environnemental de
la de la viande vous avez commencé à en
parler tout à l'heure
quel lien on peut faire entre la
consommation de viande et le
réchauffement climatique
et bah ce lien il est il est assez
explicite disons l'alimentation c'est
24% des émissions des Français et des
Françaises et si on décompose ces 24%,
les produits d'origine animale si on
exclut tout ce qui est boisson vraiment
tous les aliments c'est à peu près les
trois quarts et la viande c'est à peu
près la moitié c'est pour ça que les
scénarios dont je parlais tout à l'heure
les scénarios de l'ADN la transition
l'agence de la transition écologique les
scénarios les études scientifiques table
sur cette 50% de diminution sans quoi on
pourra pas respecter les objectifs de la
France d'atteindre la neutralité carbone
en 2050 et je voulais revenir sur la
question des prairies puisque les
prairies de permanences sont
indispensables pour atteindre neutralité
carbone parce que ce sont des puits de
carbone naturelle c'est exactement alors
après qui ont une durée de stockage du
carbone donc durant plusieurs décennies
cette on a dû stockage additionnel tous
les ans après il y a pas de stockage
additionnel donc ça ne compense pas les
émissions de l'élevage mais il faut les
garder absolument après on peut réduire
le cheptel surtout pour les élevages les
plus intensifs et il faut aussi rappeler
que la baisse de la consommation et la
production de viande de porc et de
volaille ne pose pas trop de problèmes
pour les prairies vu que c'est des
élevages qui sont à 83% pour les poulets
95% pour le port en France en bâtiment
donc avec des vertus de stockage du
carbone et de biodiversité strictement
nul les mêmes les impacts négatifs par
rapport au climat et il y a pas de doute
sur cette sujet-là en fait si on veut
garder un monde vivable la consommation
elle s'impose mais en privilégiant des
élevages qui sont durables donc ils
demandent moins d'importations pour
l'alimentation animale par exemple
pourquoi parce qu'on apporte beaucoup de
soja c'est ça par exemple on apporte
beaucoup de soja dans les rations de des
élevages de volailles de porc une partie
des élevages laitiers aussi et il y a
aussi besoin de beaucoup de maïs
irrigués or le maïs irrigué demande
beaucoup d'eau et avec le changement
climatique ça va poser de très gros
problèmes l'avenir Guillaume Gauthier je
rappelle que vous êtes responsable
environnement pour l'association
nationale interprofessionnelle du bétail
et les viandes ça veut dire que vous
réfléchissez à la façon de continuer de
proposer de la viande de qualité en
ayant moins d'impact environnemental
oui oui c'est notre travail au quotidien
enfin c'est quand je monte à Paris
justement et là j'ai été tout à l'heure
justement
c'est des réflexions mais c'est plutôt
c'est plutôt une réflexion pour mettre
en valeur ce qui est ce que vous avez
parlé c'est-à-dire la prairie permanente
les prairies voilà on est on éleveur de
ruminants donc qui rumine et 6 rumine ce
qui mangent des prairies enfin de
l'herbe et c'est pas seulement beaucoup
pour le paysage c'est effectivement
c'est pas seulement beau pour les
paysages c'est bon pour nos animaux
c'est bon pour la biodiversité nos haies
nos arbres sont aussi des des
atouts essentiels pour la biodiversité
donc on essaye de que on est conscient
qu'effectivement que que la viande de
ruminant enfin le ruminant donc du coup
il aimait des gaz à effet de serre et ça
il n'y a pas de problème sur ce sujet on
a des seuls secteurs qui compense une
grosse partie de nos émissions faut
grâce aux prairies grâce au prairies
notamment mais aujourd'hui on peine à
mettre en avant ses prairies à mettre en
valeur cette quantité de biodiversité de
captation de carbone etc et du coup ça
pèse beaucoup sur notre
nos élevages et c'est même assez
malheureux parce que finalement
allez je suis pas ma foi m'attirer les
foudres de mes collègues mais l'élevage
herbivore français par les vaches
allaitantes par les vaches laitières etc
voilà c'est quand même une chose qui est
rare c'est un élevage le plus durable au
monde enfin je pense qu'on a besoin
d'une politique globale il faut pas
s'attaquer juste en disant il faut qu'on
réduise le cheptel pour pour émettre
moins de carbone il faut qu'on pense à
l'avenir au prairie à dire il y a des
territoires peut-être un petit peu trop
intensifs et encore sur les éleveurs de
ruminants j'en connais pas beaucoup il y
a des élevages très très extensifs il
faut qu'on préserve ça c'est passé quoi
le bon ratio combien de vaches
à l'hectare je sais pas c'est je sais
pas si s'il y a une vache et demie avec
un veau à l'hectare une vache avec un
veau à l'hectare en plein été c'est ce
qui se passe dans la majorité des
prairies françaises bien évidemment
l'hiver quand il fait mauvais elles sont
rentrées en bâtiment pour pour mettre
bas après il y a la façon de de
l'engraissement vous avez dit les
hectares de mes sentinages on élevage de
de
bovins-lestan c'est pas la majorité de
la la ration elle repose vraiment sur
l'herbe l'herbe consommer l'été auprès
et la récolter pour consommer vous
pouvez éviter de d'importer du soja par
exemple vous en élevage à l'état on
consomme très très peu de soja quand on
veut chercher de la protéine alors on a
une façon aussi de le faire par de la
luzerne par des protéines comme ça qu'on
fait chez nous et on est plus sur du
colza français du tourteau de colza
français et notamment en élevage
allaitant pour terminer sur ce survolet
écologique je vous propose un témoignage
d'une explication c'est Richard Connor
qui est auteur principal du rapport de
l'Unesco sur l'eau en 2023 et il lit le
risque de crise mondiale de l'eau à
l'élevage à la consommation de viande
dans l'écoute
ce que nous pouvons faire
individuellement ne concerne pas
seulement la façon dont nous contrôlons
le robinet nous pouvons aussi agir par
le biais de notre alimentation par
exemple la viande rouge est extrêmement
gourmande en eau vous savez qu'il faut
environ litres d'eau pour produire 1 kg
de bœuf alors en faisant un petit effort
sur votre alimentation par exemple si
vous mangez de la viande trois fois par
semaine et que vous essayez de plus en
manger qu'une fois une fois et demi en
moyenne alors vous économisez énormément
d'eau
une prise de parole chacun là dessus
puis ensuite on parlera des alternatives
à la viande ça sera notre dernier
chapitre 1000 litres d'eau pour produire
un kilo de bœuf doux il sort ce chiffre
comment il s'explique alors je pense que
sur ce sujet technique je préfère
laisser la parole à mon collègue que
vous assumez pas forcément ce chiffre
parce que moi je l'entends ça fait des
années que je l'entends ce chiffre c'est
un chiffre qui est controversé mais je
veux quand même dire quelques mots ça
dépend beaucoup du mode d'élevage en
fait vous avez des données qui sont
données là dans un rapport international
on se base probablement sur une
moyennisation des modes d'élevage comme
on l'a dit l'élevage bovin française
surtout pour l'élevage allaitant donc la
vache à viande ce qui est un peu
différent après de l'élevage laitier si
on compare avec les autres formes
d'élevage bovants dans le monde c'est
beaucoup plus durable et on estime qu'il
y a quand même encore des efforts à
faire en termes d'alimentation encore
davantage à l'herbe et aussi en termes
d'intensité par rapport au nombre
d'animaux à l'hectare mais qu'on a quand
même un modèle il manque pas grand chose
pour être sur quelque chose durable en
terme de mode d'élevage par contre
d'autres types de viande on a des très
fortes consommations d'eau si on va
regarder les élevages de porc ou de
volaille pour produire en fait toute
l'alimentation animale donc ça va ça
dépend vraiment de la viande dont on
parle et de la façon dont elle est ce
chiffre là 1000 litres d'eau pour un
kilo de viande ça vous dirige le poil
quand vous l'entendez non mais c'est
encore un argument de plus sur sur qui
pèse sur nos épaules en disant ben il
faut pas consommer de viande rouge ou
enfin il a dit viande il a pas précisé
et c'est un petit peu dommage pour moi
que je suis éleveur de viande rouge mais
moi j'avais plus un 50 litres d'eau en
tête parce qu'effectivement pour
produire 1 kg de viande rouge c'est 50
litres d'eau oui c'est c'est dans dans
la filière c'est c'est ce qu'on
c'est ce qu'on a coach web comme chiffre
alors bien évidemment si on prend l'eau
de pluie qui tombe sur nos prairies on
peut monter très très très élevé mais
s'il y a pas de vache il y a quand même
de l'autre celui qui tombe sur la
prairie non ce qui est ton plus beaucoup
là
ouais moi j'ai un peu de chance à cette
année donc j'espère que ça va durer je
vais croiser les doigts non non mais
il faut faire attention surtout c'est
enjeux-là je pense qu'il y a vraiment et
je le redis il faut vraiment avoir une
politique de de long terme pas une
politique électoraliste c'est à dire
qu'il faut pas aller sur je vais dire ça
parce que je vais être élu mais si je
dis ça mais vraiment sur un global la
gestion de l'herbe la gestion de l'air
la gestion de l'eau les prairies sont
des dans les très très bons filtres pour
l'eau d'ailleurs si vous mettez une
carte une superposition de la qualité de
l'eau et des prairies vous aurez
exactement le très bon emplacement où il
y a des prairies la qualité de l'eau
elle est très très bonne donc il faut
faire attention quand on dit il faut
réduire la consommation de viande en
France allez je reprends la maps il nous
reste une chronique celle de Quentin
calmé on va parler des alternatives à la
viande et notamment je vous avais pas
oublier quand tu as évidemment la viande
in vitro alors pardon parce que vu
l'heure vous allez peut-être passer à
table bientôt mais que c'est c'est quoi
la viande in vitro une vitraux
c'est-à-dire en milieu artificiel en
laboratoire on pense à de la viande
créée en fait à partir d'une première
cellule et qui ensuite développer dans
ce qu'on appelle un bioréacteur c'est
une innovation qui est en cours dans
plusieurs startups de Parlement et ça a
donné même et bien de sacrées
innovations comme par exemple cet énorme
mythe-ball de viande une boulette de
viande de mammouth elle a été présentée
sous une cloche de verre en mars dernier
sur une fake news
c'est le défi que c'était lancer des
scientifiques d'une société australienne
selon elle la boule de protéines du PC
ouvrirait la voix aux aliments du futur
rien de moins elle était con sur
laboratoire on l'a dit sur plusieurs
semaines à partir de l'année de l'ADN de
la myoglobine de mammouth protéines qui
donnerait sa saveur à la viande les
trous dans la séquence ont été combinés
avec des gènes d'éléphants d'Afrique
lorsqu'il y avait des problèmes dans la
séquence d'ADN ah oui car elle est les
fonds d'Afrique en fait le parent le
plus proche du mammouth c'est qu'en tout
cas on a lu un sur l'Agence France
Presse écoutez Tim and no ex Smith il
est cofondateur de l'entreprise à
l'origine de cette innovation
vous pouvez utiliser la boulette de
viande de mammouth comme un symbole d'un
avenir passionnant meilleur pour la
planète et éviter les dangers de ce que
nous avons connu à l'origine avec le
mammouth laineux et peut-être manger
pour échapper à l'extinction en clair et
bien en résolvant certaines
problématiques de l'élevage intensif
cette viande in vitro ou on l'appelle
aussi aliments cellulaire pour
réapporter des solutions aux
problématiques environnementales en tout
cas ce que disent les promoteurs de
cette et le Sénat a travaillé sur cette
question rendu un rapport c'était en
mars dernier sujet quand même assez
épineux pour la chambre des territoires
bien sûr les sénateurs n'ont pas voulu
donner l'impression de soutenir les
concurrents des agriculteurs classiques
lors des auditions on avait vu une
certaine tension entre les promoteurs de
ces technologies et les défenseurs de
l'élevage alors en tout cas cette
pratique elle avait interrogé Thierry
Marx qui avait été reçu le chef étoilé
un en audition il a étudié la question
dans son centre de recherche écouter son
analyse c'était en février dernier
dans un pays où déjà on a une fracture
alimentaire au-delà d'avoir une fracture
sociale et bien c'est compliqué c'est
encore de l'ultra transformé pour les
plus modestes qui sont éloignés d'un
reste à vivre alimentaire suffisant donc
ça nous inquiète un petit peu parce que
là il y a pas de goût le peu qu'on est
goûté et notamment sur les Nuggets et
bien il a fallu pour leur donner une
saveur et une texture les aromatiser on
sait comment l'industrie aromatise tout
ça et
se restaurer c'est pas ça c'est vraiment
ramener dans l'assiette une histoire un
savoir manger un savoir-être autour de
la table voilà on va se débat déjà sur
cette viande dans leur rapport les
sénateurs rappellent que 110 un certain
nombre de startups qui dans le monde ont
investi ce secteur de la viande in vitro
il rappelle qu'aucune demande de
commercialisation n'existe encore en
Europe et eux ils recommandent de
proscrire l'utilisation du mot viande
lorsque l'on parle de cette matière
scientifique là qui est en cours de
création et d'interdire aussi le mélange
entre viande d'élevage la viande de
laboratoire merci beaucoup Quentin calmé
je vais vous faire un aveu ce soir il y
a un match de Ligue des Champions je
vais peut-être me commander un burger
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que j'irai pas
manger de la de la viande de il y en a
un ce soir et un demain oui il y en a il
y en a il y en a tous les soirs ou
presque mais j'irai pas me commander de
la viande de synthèse ça c'est sûr les
mots on leur importance c'est
intéressant en consommation ne pas
appeler viande quelque chose qui n'est
pas de la viande ça c'est un c'est un
bras de fer c'est un enjeu important des
années à venir d'après vous c'est un
enjeu de de transparence d'honnêteté de
repères aussi pour pour les
consommateurs c'est c'est déjà il y a
beaucoup de difficultés à se repérer
aujourd'hui mais cette demande qui n'a
fait que croître de traçabilité de
savoir ce qu'il y a sur les de regarder
les étiquettes et de savoir ce qu'il y a
de sucer c'est quelque chose auquel les
consommateurs sont de plus en plus de
plus en plus attachés mais pour revenir
sur cette viande de synthèse en fait
pour le coup ça va ça va vraiment à
rebours avec les imaginaires actuelles
c'est à dire justement ce qui ce que on
perçoit dans nos études c'est ce qui est
questionné c'est justement notre modèle
de développement industriel appliqué à
l'alimentaire et ses excès en fait qui
pourquoi est-ce que ça il y a une
inflexion dans les années 90 parce qu'à
ce moment-là justement il y a eu un tas
de plusieurs crises en fait à répétition
autour de la viande mais pas que des
crises des crises alimentaires qui ont
interrogé ce modèle industriel et la
prolongation de ça c'est effectivement
tout ce qu'on peut faire et en France
par exemple sur les OGM ou sur tout ce
qui est de synthèse en fait des prolongé
ça et que la technologie
prolonge ça c'est quelque chose qui pour
le moment n'est pas très acceptable pour
le consommateur on a un peu de mal à
l'imaginer en France aujourd'hui qui a
une vraie question et je vais en
terminer là-dessus avec vous Benoit
Granier sur ce qu'on sait de ces de ces
viandes une vitraux là parce que il y a
une tribune publiée dans le monde je
crois que c'était fin février 25 février
par une soixantaine de scientifiques qui
disaient grosso modo mais on sait pas on
sait pas quels sont les effets de cette
zone de synthèse sur la même sur
l'environnement etc etc faudrait
peut-être qu'on se pose cette question
avant de la produire quoi oui c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas de recul on
connaît mal les impacts environnementaux
et puis pour la santé et surtout ce qui
pose aussi question c'est qu'aujourd'hui
l'assiette durable de demain qui est
bonne pour la santé bonne pour la
planète on la connaît déjà c'est moins
de viande mais de meilleure qualité plus
de fruits et légumes plus de céréales
complètes plus de légumineuses faut
savoir qu'aujourd'hui plus de la moitié
des Français ont des carences en fibres
mange pas assez de légumineuses pas
assez de fruits et légumes les aliments
qu'il faut mettre davantage dans
l'assiette c'est vraiment ces aliments
là et à côté de ça si on a un niveau
d'élevage qui est de type durable et qui
est modérée en termes de nombre
d'animaux ça peut être tout à fait
durable également bref de la middle de
mammouth je suis pas près de manger
on est d'accord merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce à ce débat
je vous dis à bientôt sur sur Public
Sénat voilà fin de cette émission je
vous donne rendez-vous demain 18h et 22h
pour un nouveau numéro de sens public
vous pouvez aussi retrouver notre
mission tous les programmes de la chaîne
sur notre plateforme Public Sénat point